non
oh surprise que tu as to roll
[Musique]
chaque fois on fait on fait rentrer un
tableau qui ne sert à rien puisque il
n'écrit jamais la réponse dessus comme
un école comme à l'école alors maxime 6
alors là comme vous êtes très bon j'ai
décidé qu'il fallait répondre trois sur
trois y aura trois cas sur trois sur
trois c'est donc si vous ne remportez
pas brillamment ce défi de
l'intervention psg ce qui va se passer
vraiment le facebook live pendant la pub
vous allez devoir procéder à l'élection
de mister camping dans le public
chadarevian avec comme jury trois femmes
d'exception
géraldine divine finalement c'est sur ce
qui pourrait devenir le second des six
n'est pas une femme d'exception à la
alors si c'est une femme exceptionnelle
mais pas l'exception
il faut s'aimer basse et le promets
non mais non mais non c'est mieux juste
savoir du piquant il est très bon maxime
kenny de maille écouté hier il a
remporté il va les rencontrer
contrairement à vous et je sais qu'il a
travaillé à la tension premières
questions questions sur le film au à la
légende qui sort le 6 juin donc au début
du film le personnage principal
basketteurs donc lauriane sic on
retrouve son club formateur qu'elle est
la ville de ce club facile passé toulon
revoir ces engins
il y avait un grand tissu avec marc et
roger yves bost qu'est ce qu'il est bon
c'est vrai que sur cette photo on voit
bien que c'est marqué c'est non mais
attendez il a déjà perdu alors attendez
à ce qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est une vidéo
la réponse est évidemment en images on
image regardez comme c'est bon t'es fini
ton shula alors que les choses soient
claires je me fous complètement est ce
que vous pensez moi je suis venu ici
c'est uniquement pour jouer au basket et
donner le maximum pour cette équipe et
qui problème des cochons fou alors deux
solutions soit vous comporter comme des
professionnels
bonjour ensemble en serre même un aussi
bon jour et tout se passera bien
sinon je peux vous garantir que la
saison est très longue surtout pour vous
mettre en confiance parce qu'on essaie
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant tous oui oui non mais bon
chez voilà c'est comme le basket c'est
du cinéma
d'accord bon ok vous avez répondu très
mal la plaque à tensions internes ou
comment s'appellent vous comment
s'appelait le personnage de géraldine
lapalus dans camping paradis
diffusée sur tf1 7 j 2 avant dean alors
oui de 2006 à 2016 dans ma copine
paradis quand même et oui quand même
quand même alors si vous répondez bien à
la question qui suit j'ai perdu
bah oui vous aurez gagné un élan de
générosité oh non écoutez j'ai eu des
ordres donc respecté mes ordres
attention donnez moi et je vous hop je
fais je fais le tour tonus il vous
répondez correctement
[Applaudissements]
donnez moi le nom de tous les acteurs
qui ont joué un gendarme principal dans
la série des films des gendarmes de jean
girault tous les temps d'accès et on
accepte au moins cinq noms étaient très
difficiles comme les deux finales et
c'est ce pari idiot de dire je me
mettrais toni n'est ce pas de funès vous
évidemment normal il ya notre mieux je
vois la tête
non très avait quand même une fois qu'on
a à faire ainsi des coûts présenté comme
quelqu'un qui est très très fort la
brune galabru oui lefebvre le ferry
estimé christian marin parce qu'il est
normatif maurice risch
d'où d'ailleurs rosso je rends
pierre-henri grosso modo je me les
refaire devrait diffuser le trèbes et
patrick préjean évidemment
oui allez donc très content et donc vous
allez devoir chercher des vacances donc
le donc vous allez faire l'élection de
miss camping camping très bien mr campé
pendant la pub un garçon donc mr mister
pas miss mister mistercamping mister à
ce mélange passe là bas vous aussi en
même temps comment la prochaine d'accord
il va falloir donc dans le jury
évidemment géraldine et magali allez
vous asseoir
[Applaudissements]